so a few months ago I was cleaning out
the Attic my childhood home when I
stumbled across my 8th grade journal in
eighth grade I had buck teeth
size 11 shoes and long skinny toothpick
legs I open the journal and dust it off
and found one particularly interesting
entry it was about what my life would be
like at age thirty in eighth grade I
predicted that by now I would be married
with two kids play professional football
for the Denver Broncos and own a
self-driving car see when I was young I
wanted to be an astronaut I wanted to be
the second Neil to step foot on the moon
the first doctor to cure cancer but as I
got older voices and doubts told me I
wasn't gonna play football that being an
astronaut
it's not a reasonable career and they're
curing cancer
good luck these voices still plague me
today Outer Critics says you can't work
at X company
they only hire engineers and when I
think about raising my hand in class I
immediately put it down because I'm
worried that what I'm gonna say isn't
smart enough
the voices the voices in my head keep me
wishing and wanting rather than daring
and doing but I realized I'm not alone I
conducted a survey and asked over 50
people this one question I wish I had
the courage to one of my friends said I
wish I had the courage to bring up an
uncomfortable topic at the GSB that I
wouldn't be judged for saying it another
person said I wish I had the courage to
leave my high-paying job and start a
company another person said I wish I had
the courage to tell my parents I'm gay
what do you wish you had the courage to
do so the problem is is these voices of
doubt of fear they're crippling our
relationships they're hindering our
potential they're telling us you know
what get back in line play it safe
follow the herd see the opposite of
courage is not cowardice its conformity
the opposite of courage is not cowardice
its conformity there was something about
finding my 8th grade journal that
brought me back to my junior year of
college it was a cold winter night and I
was in an empty College football stadium
I was cleaning it because I was earning
money because I was a student at BYU I
swept soggy popcorn and half-eaten
burritos with other trash I collected it
by hand
I looked up from the trash at the empty
field what happened to the dreams I had
as a kid to play college football
see voices told me voice is a fear of
doubt you know what
you can't put you're a junior now you
can't play Division one football
especially not a team that's ranked
seventh in the nation one kid said dude
you're not gonna play in the NFL so why
don't you spend your time looking for a
job
couple weeks passed and my roommate Josh
he entered my room where I was laying on
my bed resigned to my current place in
life Neil I signed you up for tryouts he
said as he handed me the paper you can
do it I realized that it was easier to
not try out than to try out and fail but
I remember the words of my high school
coach there's no shoulda woulda coulda
there's only I did so despite enormous
doubt given my limited eligibility my
small stature my just all this doubt I
courageously confronted my fear and
tried out and to be honest it felt a
little bit like this
it's not the outcome that mattered but
for me it was that I faced my fear and
did something I wanted to do I made a
team that winner only to be cut in the
spring but with newfound conviction that
what I was doing mattered to me it
didn't matter what anybody else said it
mattered to me I attacked 5:00 a.m.
workouts in an abandoned field near my
house I ran sprints ran upstairs till I
wanted to puke I came back that fall I
tried out again and I made the team
I remember standing on the field after
the final game under the lights I looked
up into the stands were just the season
before I was cleaning up trash I can't
believe I almost didn't try out
satisfaction came from being true to
myself what matters to you
what are you committed to do you find
yourself wanting and wishing or daring
and doing
do you find yourself standing in the
stands or playing on the field
it's been said that if what we believe
is different than what we do we will
never be happy if what we believe is
different than what we do we will never
be happy
Steve Jobs said it like this your time
is limited so don't waste it living
someone else's life
don't let the voice of others opinions
drown out your own inner voice and have
the courage to be true to your heart and
intuition they somehow already know what
you want to truly become everything else
is secondary
you know what's interesting about Steve
Jobs he was cut from his team think
about Thomas Edison his teacher said you
you're not smart enough to learn Walt
Disney was fired from the newspaper for
lacking imagination and creativity these
were people who were committed to
something greater than their fear it's
funny to me to think about you know what
would a world be like if Jobs had given
up if Edison and Disney had listened no
phones no lights no Lion King
no Mustafa Hakuna Matata no goofy no
Donald Duck hanging in my bedroom wall
next to where my eighth grade journal
now sit is a quote that I look to when I
face fear it's kind of long and you've
probably heard it before
but I want you to think about one thing
that you wish you were doing now what
you're not Teddy Roosevelt said this
it's not the critical counts not the man
who points out where the strong man
stumbles or where the doer of Deeds
could have done them better the credit
belongs to the man who is actually in
the arena whose face is marred with dust
and sweat and blood who strives
valiantly who airs and comes short again
and again who knows the great
enthusiasms the great devotions who
spends himself in a worthy cause and who
at worst it fails at least fails while
daring greatly so that his place shall
never be with those cold and timid souls
who know neither victory nor defeat
my ask of you when voices of doubt and
fear enter your mind when critics tell
you you can't go ahead and do it anyways
dare to leave the stands and enter the
arena because real satisfaction comes
from being true to yourself thank you